欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲关于爆品提升的方法
总共有哪些方法,以及它规则是怎么样的
我们怎么样才能够更快的提升这些爆品
首先我们来看一下它的一个具体的指标是怎么样的
首先第一个就是定制的产品
它要满足产品信息质量分在4.2分以上
近90天, TM和循环的人数需要多少个
通常来说,大概在20个上下
不同的行业,数据不一样
我们刚才已经讲过怎么样去看了
去准报品里面去看一个具体的指标
参考它的就可以了
那么近90天,提升的循环转化率要达到多少
其实基本不用看
只要你这个上面这个达标的话
99.9%都是能够成为爆品的
因为只要你这里有数据那么你的转化率肯定不会太低
那么RTS产品的话也是一样
这是最基本的信息质量分要在4.2分以上
同时呢它这里是支付的买家数
这个也是在准爆品里面去看
你的订单到底有多少个
通常来说可能10个有些行业, 10个有些行业
多一点有些行业少一点
那么你要去看这个也是基本不用看因为只要你这个支付买家数足够多那么你的买家转化率肯定是不会太低的那么这个就是我们的爆品的一个基本的一个数据指标这是非常明确的你只需要去把产品的各项指标做成达标就能够变成实力优品那么这个是不同行业
不同行业会有不同的数据, 我们需要具体的看你是哪个行业, 以及后台显示的是哪个数值, 一切以后台的数值为准, 数据是会波动变化的, 也就是按照90天的动态, 你看这些都是按照90天的数据在变化的, 所以说如果你超过90天, 或者是在最近90天内, 这些数据又不达标了, 那么
你这个爆品可能就变成了准爆品, 也就是离爆品还差一点点, 这时候你就要重品去关注你的爆品数据了, 如果它跌下来了, 那么你就要尽快的去补充这些数据, 就可以让它能够在短期内快速的恢复, 那么我们来讲一下提升爆品的十个方法, 如何提升这些爆品的重量, 第一个, 我们也是通过直通车进行强推, 来实现它
成为爆品
同时结合问鼎跟鼎掌
这些资源, 如果你没有这些资源, 那么你直接用自动车就可以了
那么最快的路径成为爆品, 从实力优品里面去挑选产品, 去选择那些
离我们上面这些指标差距很小的
去把这些产品选择进来推
用爆品助推计划去推
推广到一定程度, 如果是你效果好的话
或者是效果不好的话
那么你就继续用优爆品出推
要么你就持续更换成为关键词计划
这些计划都可以
具体选择哪个计划
你可以参考我们前面所学的直通车推广方面的方法
去选择计划和设置计划就可以了
这些方法我们前面都讲过
在直通车板块都讲过了
你就按照那里面的方法去操作就可以了
第二个路径就是通过平台的新品去选品,也就是去选择最近非常有潜力的产品,也就是可能在一到两周之内,它寻盘量非常多,而且是增长的很快的,那么这种产品拿去推广,直接用新品加速计划去推广,然后在后期再用优报品注推计计划,或者关键词推广计划,这些都可以去实现,那么这些至于怎么操作,
你直接参考和学习我们对应的计划的方法就可以了
那么剩下的六种类型的优品呢
我们统一用普通品计划或者是优报品助推这些都可以
那么你就要去看这些优报品它本身的数据怎么样
再决定去选择你所用的推广计划就可以了
我这里讲的直动车推广这里有三条路径
也就是你可以选择实力优品去推也可以选择平台新品去推或者是选择其他类型的优品去推广至于你选择了之后你这一计划的话你就按照实际的去来去选就可以了然后把它们变成准报品准报频到最终成为报品达标第二种方法就是很快的比如说你有些商家他资源非常多他有很多老客户那么你线下直接把这些订单拉上来绑定
这些RTS来增加买家数, 那么你这个RTS就很快很快就成为爆品了, 比如说他只需要10个买家数, 那么你直接绑定10个线下买家, 那么他是不是很快就成为爆品了, 这个定制产品即使他成为不了爆品, 只要你绑定他的订单是不是他的权重非常高, 是不是他排名会更好, 排名好了是不是有更多机会获得悬盘, 让更
更多的人看到, 是不是, 询盘一增长, 比如说达标了, 那么是不是他也变成了, 爆品了, 第三个第四的话都是采用
买家账号去进行补询盘, 或者是补订单的, 这些补询盘的话, 跟补订单的话, 需要你有自己的账号, 去进行补充就可以了, 这里补的一定要注意, 补那些缺一点点订单, 或者是一点点询盘的, 你千万不要去
全部都是靠补单去实现的这种话不理想而且是效果很差的你要去把握那些
效果比较好的但是他缺一点点的你又想做缩短时间
让这个产品快速成为爆品的那么这种方式就可以在这里使用了第五个就是挖掘蓝牌产品和市场破解需求的产品因为市场需求越大那么他
能够获得的流量就越快而且他能够得到更多的人青睐
所以你的循环才会更加快的增长
第六个就是把定制产品改成RTS产品
这个是有一个前提,这里有一个前提就是你这个产品一定要确保他能够做
RTS的
另一个就是你这个产品
的买家数已经足够成为爆品了,比如说爆品需要10个买家
但是你这个产品呢
定制产品成为不了爆品因为需要20个循环
所以你想把它改成
RTS产品那么你直接把它改,改了之后它只要有符合10个
订单那么它或10个买家那么它就能够成为爆品
这里要注意一个点
如果你本身这个产品的效果
很好
那么我是不建议你去更改的
除非你这个
产品本来是
实力优品
但是呢它本身的
寻盘啊
曝光点击量都比较少的情况下你在用这种方法
这种方法尽量少用在那些数据好的产品上面, 一定是用在那些数据差的产品上面的
才用这个方法让它成为
真爆品,这个方法
很少人会去使用,也很少人敢这样敢
第7第8第9第10
这几个板块跟我们
提升实力优品的方法
其实是一样的
那么这些方法都是
去
把你的
想要提升的这些产品去报
反客营销, EDM 营销, 还有报
那么第八个就是参加官方的活动用你的
非常好的
现货产品去参加设置折扣,同时呢定制产品也可以参加平台的其他活动
这些都是可以的
直播的时候你要绑定一些你
最近想推的产品
或者是你想把它提升成为爆品的产品,让客户去点击
让客户去发旋盘就可以达成了
最后一个就是短视频发布的时候我们绑定产品的时候
一定去绑定当前效果比较好的而且数据是比较好的那种产品就可以了
那么这整个就是关于爆品提升的方法
我们可以选择其中几种适合自己用的方法去提升就可以了
如果你现在缺少方法你可以每个都去尝试
那么这样的话你的成功的概率会更大
那么关于爆品这个我们要选的产品一定是从这里选的爆品,从准爆品里面去选,选一些数据非常接近它的爆品标准的产品就可以了,也可以从这里新品这里去选,有些新品它循环也是非常非常好的,新品可能也可能是准爆品,因为它们之间是重合的,也就是说平台新品里面可能会有一些准爆品,
因为品台新品它没有达标成为爆品也可能在这里那么实力优品里面你也可以去根据这些数据去挖掘一些好的产品你要去时常的去看一下每周或者是有空的时候多去看一下挖掘一下这些产品另外的那我们也可以在直接在这个产品参谋这里去看去挖掘你按周每周就去看一下现在的
寻盘有寻盘的
但是他
差多少成为爆品的
你就按照这种思路去
筛选一些产品出来,还有TM的这些筛选出来
这样的话
那么你做的事情就更加简单
而且你能够把这些产品变成爆品的概率就更大
这个就是1U如何去提供爆品重量的方法
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
希望这节课你要重视起来并行动起来